Here to share
their reporting at the table is CNN's
Jeff Zeleny.
Sang one
song,
Min Kim
Forgive Me of the Associated Press
and Leann
Caldwell of The Washington Post.
Nice to see you all.
So, Jeff, I want to start with you.
And I actually want to
probably say
that I have had the experience
and I'm guessing all of you had.
With the in-box
infiltrated by the Trump
campaign's fundraising
appeals,
I mean, it just kept coming last night
when you arrest your leading
political opponent, opponent,
we no longer have a democracy.
400 years in prison.
My thought this is from his son.
My father has been arraigned
at the Miami Federal Courthouse.
I mean, these were just coming nonstop.
They are.
And that's obviously
part of the strategy to flood the zone
I thought it was interesting.
One thing that Kristen said,
and I've been hearing that as well,
it's consuming him,
but it's also consuming
and flooding into this race.
And that contributes
to the Trump exhaustion.
So we know one thing in the short term,
the arraignment was certainly better than
an arraignment should be.
He made the best.
He made lemonade
out of an arraignment day.
Let's leave it at that.
But the reality is,
we know that there's Trump
fatigue out there.
We know that many Republicans
want to turn the page.
So this contributes to it.
But clearly,
he is trying to blend the courtroom
to the campaign trail
to make this all about him.
But you wonder if that's what Republicans
want to talk about.
Many Republicans want to make this race
about Joe Biden.
They want to make this race
about inflation.
They want to win back the White House.
So nothing that has happened in the last
a few days
since we've learned about this
arraignment, it's
maybe help Donald Trump,
but it has not helped
the effort of winning back
the White House.
So that is what is sort of at odds here.
Yeah.
Building off what you just said,
I just talked
to a Republican donor this morning
who is helping to recruit people in down
ballot races in the Senate. In the House.
And this person said
that there is widespread concern that
these candidates
are not going to be able to talk
about the economy.
About the border, about inflation.
Instead,
there's a lot of concern
that Donald Trump
is just going to suck up all the oxygen
in a 20, 24 election
and leave little room
for what
they actually want to campaign on.
And let's be clear,
obviously, we are talking about it today
extensively
because it happened yesterday.
But we're also talking about it
because he keeps talking about.
Right. Right.
He didn't just kind of ignore it
and then move on to
taking Joe Biden to task on the economy.
He talked about himself.
And as much as he has
that sort of public bravado, as bravado,
as much as the campaign is saying
that they believe that this,
at least in the short term
as a political win
something that his former
chief of staff,
John Kelly, said in The Washington
Post, really drew our attention.
I just want to read it.
Here's what he said.
He's scared less I can figure that out.
This is the way he compensates for that.
He gives people the appearance.
He doesn't care
by doing this
for the first time in his life.
It looks like he's
going to be held accountable.
Up until this point in his life,
it's like, I'm not going to pay you.
Take me to court.
He's never been held accountable before.
Right.
And I think that's sort of
if you look at some of the reporting
out there that says
publicly he is
projecting this error of confidence,
he's really trying to seize this
as an opportunity
to bolster his campaign profile.
But internally,
I mean, these are very serious charges.
And it is not just
these charges in federal court.
It is not just for hush money.
Payment accusations.
New York has two more
potential indictments
coming and other criminal matters.
I mean, these are very serious charges.
And again,
you can try to make some
you know,
lemons out of lemonade,
but the lemons are initially sour
in the first place.
He's not dealing with
a very good situation at all.
And just as a contrast
as he tries to talk about Biden
and as Republicans
want to try to focus more on Biden
and the economy.
This the
the White House,
the president is kind of burying
their heads in the sand,
deliberately staying quiet about it.
And I think for them,
this creates a contrast
that they actually like,
that they are doing their job.
They are doing normalcy.
And and this is the chaos
in the Republican Party today.
A new fiery condemnation.
Mike Pence slammed
Donald Trump over the former
president's alleged
handling of classified documents.
I had
a chance to review
the indictment over the weekend.
And this indictment contains
serious charges.
And I cannot defend what is alleged.
And for Pence, whose son is a Marine.
It's personal.
Highly sensitive classified material
could have fallen
into the wrong
hands, even inadvertently,
that that jeopardizes
our national security and puts at risk
the men and women of our armed forces.
Our great reporters are back
here around the table.
What do you make of the Mike Pence
sort of ramping up slowly
but very much surely?
Look, I think it's significant
particularly saying
that his son is a Marine
and he's following in the footsteps
of what
Nikki Haley said,
also drawing the national security
point to it.
Look for all the drama
that surrounds
this and the Trump going to her side,
going to Bedminster.
We should remember
this is about the case at hand.
This is about what's in the indictment
and national security
secrets were put at risk.
So I think that is
what if you read the indictment
and the former vice
president went on to say,
when he read the indictment,
read the indictment,
John Bolton said
the RNC should send the indictment
to every Republican voter.
That obviously won't happen.
But when you read the RNC,
you should do that.
John Bolton said the RNC showed it.
He was saying that people should read it.
And when you do read it,
the national security risk here,
I think that is something
that will matter
to some Republican voters.
By the way, I just want to say,
he didn't actually go to like France
to the first time, to the palace versus
Miami.
That had a very, very good copy.
Go ahead. Right, right, right.
What it was
certainly was a different tone
that you heard
from what you heard
from the former vice president last week.
He was cautious at that time as well.
But he did
criticize
kind of what was starting to come out
But I think for Mike Pence, Nikki Haley
and some other some other
some other Republicans as well,
this is the fundamental job
of a commander in chief.
It is to protect your country,
the citizens of your country from harm.
And I think
that's why the allegations here
and what President Trump is accused of
doing has gone too far for summer.
Okay, so you mentioned Nikki Haley.
I just before you jump in, Lynn,
I want to put up on the screen
what we have seen and heard from her
over the past few days on Friday.
People are exhausted by the prosecutor.
Prosecutorial overreach.
Monday.
If true, Trump was incredibly reckless
with our national security.
We've got to have someone
that can win a general election.
And then yesterday,
I would be inclined in favor of a pardon.
I was saying earlier, it's
almost like you're
taking the journey with her
on the political battlefield.
Trying to avoid all of the landmines.
Well, yeah.
I mean,
so the challenging thing
for these Republican candidates
is trying to figure out
what the Republican base at
is still relatively loyal to Donald Trump
where they are.
So I'm going to be cynical
and skeptical here.
I really want to see the internal polling
that these candidates are seeing,
especially as Mike
Pence and Nikki Haley
kind of takes a more
critical turn of the former president.
Maybe they're seeing something
where his support
is actually softening
and this sticks
because ultimately they're trying to win
an election and polling matters.
Well, somebody who has money
for pretty extensive
polling is Ron DeSantis.
And I mean,
I think
CNN dot coms have been
subheadline really sums it up.
Don's everywhere. Where's Ron?
Those close to
and his campaign view
the reluctance to take on Trump as a
as a consistent
with his hopes
of eventually
winning over Trump's supporters.
If that changes,
that will be the telltale sign
you're talking about. Absolutely.
He's obviously in the Trump
lite category trying to out Trump, Trump
actually, in the commercial break,
I got a text from the dentist campaign
trying to raise money off of Joe Biden.
Oh, I thought they were going to
talk about our coverage. That's not
Is he trying to turn the focus on that?
So one of the reasons
the candidates are not out there
quite as much this week
and next is because it's
almost the end of the second quarter
for fundraising.
So it's a critical time for fundraising.
But look,
if they wanted to be out there
making noise,
they certainly know how to do that.
A run as it is
will be in Nevada over the weekend.
We'll see if he says anything
at that point.
But look, they're all sort of tiptoeing
to see where they're going.
But there is a lane in a market
among some Republicans for
someone to stand up for this.
Well, see if anyone steps into it.
Boy, do you have my card here.
You exactly just tweeted it
right up for me. It's really amazing.
Let's hear from Chris Christie
because I feel like
because it was so much news yesterday,
this is very telling
to what you're talking about,
what he told Anderson
and CNN's town hall Monday night.
Why do you think they're not addressing
what's actually in the indictment?
Because it's indefensible
and they're playing games.
Look, you all need to know this.
They're playing political games with you
because they think you kind of like Trump
a little bit.
And I don't see anything bad about Trump.
And then Trump
kind of implodes and goes away.
Then you're more likely to vote for me.
And then another roadmap for Republicans.
Most Republicans,
a lot of
Americans read The Wall Street Journal,
but it's known for its conservative
editorial board
last week, a destructive
Trump indictment.
Do prosecutors
understand the forces they're unleashing?
But yesterday, last night,
the destructive Donald Trump
the document indictment is misguided, but
he makes it easier for his enemies,
as he always does.
Self-destructive Trump.
I mean, that is a bumper sticker message
if you ever heard one.
Of course, The Wall Street
Journal editorial page
has been editorializing against Trump
for quite some time.
But it is something that shows you
that there is an audience
and a lane for this.
So we will see come August
when that first debate happens.
How many Republican rivals and candidates
are willing to take that step?
That'll tell us a lot.